[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis
u.s. chess champs calm presents the
third annual winter chess Classic
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our final
coverage of the 2019 winter chess
classic it is day nine here in st. Louis
as always we are your hosts my name is
Caleb denim joined by the wonderful
sabina for sure and we will be giving
you all of the coverage of this final
round here today in st. Louis there's an
exciting chess has happened here this
past week oh yeah absolutely and it's
it's a race to the finish
it's still a very tight near the top
anyone
well not anyone but any number of
players could actually walk home with
with the title I think there are no
fewer than three eligible and the a
group still and I think three in the B
group as well also have good chances to
force the playoff or go home with with
it and soul first yeah so we are
definitely going to be more focused on
those games specifically just our
viewers you know up-to-date with what's
happening any case we're going to have a
playoff we'll make sure to stay online
for that and absolutely discuss the
games
we'll be here for it until all is
decided why don't we actually check out
where we stand first in the a group we
have Bri not Rima buyeth and Jeffrey
Zhang both on five points out of eight
now that was of course a half point
ahead yesterday but actually lost his
game - Havana's Kabu Xion yeah that was
kind of unexpected an unexpected turn of
events in the a group and now Jeff is
showing we're not having a fantastic
tournament but I guess you know he's
finally due for a bad game because he
had seven great games before before this
round eight yeah that's true I mean it
happens sometimes you may run out of
energy or out of luck or just you just
simply have a bad day and the things can
turn around but you know both him and
Jeffrey are battling it out today in
some very interesting matches that we'll
take a look at and you see it and we
actually saw Jeffrey earlier he actually
lost two Renacci mabye out
I believe in round 6 and then Jeffrey of
course he lost that game and then he
came back the next day and scored a full
point really yeah so we'll see if we not
can kind of respond in kind with a win
here today to bring it home yeah yep
Jeffrey as we said also on five points
Sam setting in Seth you are both on four
and a half so both definitely within
striking distance although I believe Sam
has already drawn in his game today so
is it unlikely that that he'll be in the
playoff unless you know both are not in
and Jeffrey loose which is unlikely Seth
you though with a win today we'd move to
fight five and a half and would have
very decent chances to actually make
make a playoff yeah in case those two
players will draw their games
Jeffrey and Renaud so that remains to be
seen yeah these four players the ones to
look out for in the a group and why
don't we actually go ahead and move to
the B group and see where we stand there
Emilio Cordova is a half point ahead of
Federico Perez poncy and I believe
actually Sergei azeroth is is also
actually in five and a half not far
enough yes some small yes a small
mistake there but the ones to look out
for in the B group are Emilio Cordova
and Sergei azeroth and then Federico
polska definitely within a half point
and actually he's playing Emilio today
so if Federico manages to win his game
he will be kind of leapfrogging
Emilio and then depending on azarov's
game Federico and very well might might
be in that playoff yeah I mean oh it's
going to be interesting for sure I'm
looking forward to seeing their games
and I mean I know we we might not really
want to play off but I think it's great
for spectac this potato it's also very
excited yes players even in this last
round you know that they have everything
at stake and then in the playoff
you know you the pressure really starts
to build and for sure very exciting and
interesting to see how these players
handle it why don't we actually check
out the the format for the tournament as
well
our 210 player around Robbins of course
that's the a group and the B group that
we were just looking at the time control
for both groups is 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves then 30 minutes is added
on for the remainder of the game there's
also a 30-second increment throughout
starting on move one added on every time
you move there are of course no draw
offers allowed before Black's 30th the
move this is the draw rule in effects
here and so the only way that a game can
be drawn is by stalemate somehow or by a
three move repetition yato move 30 the
players are allowed to agree to the draw
and in the event that we do have a
playoff why don't we see what the
regulations for that are there will
first be a two-game rapid match at his
game in ten delay - so very very fast
for rapid but still within the rapid
time controls then if they tie that
match the game the entire tournament
will be decided by an Armageddon game
the Armageddon game of course white gets
five minutes with a two second increment
black only gets four minutes with that
two-second increment but has draw odds
yes how we ensure that a results is
determined that's true and this would be
by the way just in case we have just two
players dying for the top in case we
have more players with that very more
complicated yeah but let's just keep
that for now and it's like you know
rapid round robins but it's it's not
super likely to happen when we come to
yeah if we come to it well we'll discuss
the terms but for now I think that's
good to little subtle for just the match
in the Armageddon yeah and and it's nice
to have both I think because if you were
just doing Armageddon it might not be
completely fair but then even a chance
to play a couple rapid you have to prove
that you're the better player yes before
the first go straight to Armageddon when
anything could happen
yeah well as always we'd like to thank
you guys for joining us here on social
media I see a lot of you in the YouTube
chat
it's caillou a shot composer is a
familiar name Chris gates Giovanni thank
you all for joining us there we'll be
keeping an eye on the chat trying to
answer any questions you might have and
in addition to that if you want to get
involved on Twitter you can use the
hashtag winter chess classic and if you
want to follow the games for yourself as
always you can do so on us chess
Transcom follow the games live pick out
your favorite players see what the
engine has to say as well and keep
watching even if even if our show ends
you can still see those games on us
chess chairs that's true but I think
today our show will not really really
air for some time what before we get
into the pairings shot composer eyes
initiative an interesting question will
Sorkin become a grandmaster today will
he skip the ion title like kramnik go
straight to grandmaster and we forgot to
mention this looking at the standings as
well but yet Alexis or can also has a
lot on the line even if he is no longer
kind of in contention for first place
yeah I mean he if he wins his game today
he has he is going to complete his third
norm GM norm and he will get his title
his rating is been there for quite some
time now I believe so it would be it
would be certainly something a new
Grandmaster yeah but you know why don't
we actually take a look at those
pairings in the a group we have Alexis
harmonica playing sethu and that game is
actually also one of the important ones
of course that through the only other
player is still in the running
besides those two leaders really and
what's an event he had yeah he started
with the three losses and then won three
games drew and then won again it would
be an incredible story to see him win
here today for sure and
end up in somehow and apply off and win
a tournament after you're losing three
in a row
I know yeah that's like unheard of I
think that's not the most likely
unfortunately because of course Geoffrey
Noer not very strong players one of them
might be able to pull out a win today
vara Cogan has already drawn his game
with San seven so Sam going in on four
and a half out of eight today moves to
five out of nine currently tied with the
leaders but it's unlikely that that they
won't score any points yeah so Viktor
Erdos it has Havana's Kabu Xion and then
our two really key matchups of the day
are we not you mumbai of versus daniel
narrowed its key and gregorio Oberyn
versus Jeffrey Zhang
of course both Jeffrey and Rinat leading
the tournament looking to get a full
point to end it all here and why don't
we actually see what's going on in
Renaud Reema Baez game alright so this
is the current position that we have
right now Andrew Knauer 'maybe against
Daniel narrowed its key white still
seems to have a great great position a
few moments ago and we're taking a look
at this game before getting live white
had an extra pawn but no what happened
black is up a piece yeah yeah I've
received that the insider word of what's
going on in the tournament Hall Mike
comer of course our fantastic arbiter up
there says that we're not as actually
first it looked very disturbed he
started talking to himself he he was
quite upset with what just happened so
press there's just been a massive
blunder
yeah I'm really shocked I saw an extra
pawn for white and okay
pretty good equal position around here
well not equal but like pretty balanced
and why there's this kind of you know
testy a balance of the white pieces here
where white put this Queen on h3
indirectly defending this Bishop on e3
but yeah by Peter denied but felt
slightly artificial and you know it's
just too loose yeah I thought there was
a little bit too much I thought he kind
of made a lot of Queen moves after
winning the pawn of course it's not so
easy to play here on the Queen side but
eventually do need to make sure you're
not going to allow some before and so in
this position oh wow
see what happened so black played rook
to c7 in this position pretending
defending the Queen yeah mostly most
likely pretending that they wanted to
double on the C file but in the same
time defending the Queen so now black
has this threat very important capturing
the bishop and I think we not just
blundered here this is the moment he
playing Knight to f2 which simply gives
the bishop in e3 and okay white gets to
trade the Queen's and now gets this pawn
in b5 so now white is with two pawns for
the piece but that's not should I mean
not should not be sufficient actually so
we might actually see a loss here Byron
at and that will show that maybe he's
not as good as coming back after a tough
loss coming back into the tournament I
mean that's definitely a key attribute
of a lot of these top players a lot of
pressure on him of course to win the
tournament he has such a great
tournament probably one you know him and
Geoffrey have played like the best chess
maybe in the in da group if we were to
think about I think so respecting
principles playing you know correctly
positionally not blundering and now this
is this is a wonder you know like like
class players make but you know like
like made of one move threat and white
didn't see it it's very very strange
actually you know this has happened to
me once and it was very painful I was
having five out of five in the Chess
Olympiad in 2014 and the team trusted me
put me to play against friends yeah I
had this night hanging at some point and
then my opponent you know I let it
hanging there because I knew my opponent
couldn't capture it that was dick again
this kind of a pin and then she had a
move 97 protecting the rook in b8 and
attacking a bishop of my
and then you know I had the 19 see three
that was that there was no way I could
protect the two pieces of bishop in c5
419 c3 that's even a step further
removed from from this tactic right this
is this was just directs yeah rook c7
made a threat and white just did not see
it what what a tough tough moment
probably for him
yeah so Geoffrey Jean you might be
looking over at this game and thinking
oh maybe I should stop trying so hard
so this game I think you know white does
have two pawns for it but those pawns on
a2 and b2 aren't aren't going to be
horribly useful at the moment at least
so no expecting a win for Daniel right I
think so I think it's going to be very
hard but of course I don't think he's
going to give up definitely we don't
have a camera from from front to see to
see to see his you know facial
expressions but we can clearly see him
you know bouncing he said can I believe
what kind of blunder he has made
probably this is one that he'll remember
it's very tough yeah okay so assuming
that Daniel manages to win this game all
Jeffry needs is a draw to pull into the
lead
so what I'll actually take a look at
this game here here we see the players
Gregorio Pirin with the white pieces
trying to take down the young Geoffrey
Zhang yeah and if we take a look at this
position okay we see her and then give
her the opposite color bishops but we
shouldn't stop there a lot of the times
there there's this myth that opposite
color bishop end games should be a draw
and I don't really agree with it it's
really nice
so we'll see we'll see of course there's
some basis in truth right there are some
yeah but this position I I think white
kind of let go a little bit of their
advantage I think some moves back white
hand a slightly better position and
although the rook in c4 seems to be
slightly better placed
currently compared to the rook in d8 say
I don't think white white has that
many chances to rum so you might be
thinking you know why doesn't black hit
take the pone of v2 and I think the
reason is simply either
I think rook before it before ya the way
you run into back ranks you have to be
very careful of the background the line
Mike and Tweedy Bishop c3 takes on b7
takes on 85 but after Bishop c6 you're
actually ending up losing more motive
I'm not even sure Bishop takes c6 or
takes in a seventh first might be about
the same maybe yeah I think either way
you get all three of the pawns I might
be wrong but yeah this this one should
be falling very soon but but black is
not forced to go into that line I
believe right but that's one reason why
Geoffrey isn't isn't capturing b2
immediately yes for sure so if you're
black here what do you do if you want to
if you want to draw this game because I
think Geoffrey wants a draw here I mean
maybe if six I'm thinking if I'm
wondering anything tactically just
trying to break White's chain of ponds
simply you know just trade open the
rooks because it looks are perfectly
placed right now for black on the
central file so if you get to play f6
and trade I believe you have no problems
here white is going to struggle getting
there looks more active and yeah I mean
the position is maybe you know yeah tiny
bit tiny bit better maybe for black but
very tiny I mean if you put the computer
maybe it will give you like point two or
something I don't know let's see you
want to check point oh one oh wow I was
really close
all right so it's really close to equal
I mean but of course with white you have
to be able to be careful not to yeah
it's all about the activity and the rook
on c4 is slightly active right now and
with potential to come to be four but if
the black rooks managed to land on the
second-ranked for example but then of
course Geoffrey is the only one who
yeah yeah and he should feel comfortable
now knowing that every knot is not doing
so well in his his game if he has seen
it I mean we don't know if you have seen
it or not but if he has seen it and for
sure he he could be a little bit relaxed
in in this case but of course we should
not forget about with the with this turn
of events in the renowned German buy of
game and with Jeffrey's game looking to
be a draw that leaves the door open for
for Sethu to make his way into a playoff
so stuff that can win his game he will
be joining Jeffrey in the playoff
assuming these expected results stay
expected and then become actual results
let's pull that game out just for a
second for you know Wow of course look
at the time difference an hour and 20
minutes versus three that's true but
they just why just rich more 40 and I
believe the 30 minutes have been added
all right so I was worried that was that
would have been a little bit too much
for sure but still it's a it's a pretty
big gap isn't you know when you're going
to get your your 30 moves and in
unfortunately for safia
he seems to be down upon here yeah seems
to have some key issues
she takes age six was was she was just
played in this position yeah and nine
hsx played very quickly by way mm-hmm
and okay white watch is going to press a
little bit more than this in this game
black has the pair of bishops but I do
not really see a way to mate with that I
mean if you could create some some
mating attacks with the crate but I
don't really yeah it's a pawn and white
will slowly start pushing I I believe
Serena is going to to press in this game
so we might thanks looking quite nice
for Jeffrey then at the moment for sure
well while these games kind of shake
themselves out a little bit more while
things become a little bit more clear we
should actually probably take a look at
the pairings in a B group and we have
Tigran herd Union against Mellon Koch in
Aleksey Sorokin against Justin wing and
remember this Alexi Sorokin game well
not the most relevant to the B group
standings is very relevant to Alexei
soraka's chess career if he wins here
today you will be walking home with a
grand master title Christopher you is
playing L Shaun Marauder body and then
we have two really key matchups for the
day and that is emilio cordova against
sergei Arenberg and Federico Perez
sponza against Sergei Ezra off of course
Emilio Cordova and Sergei azeroth both
tied for the lead in the B group of 5
and a half points and meanwhile Federico
trills by just a half point with five
out of eight so Federico managed that
manages to defeat Sergei as rough
he moves moves to six out of nine and
we'll go into a playoff with Cordova
assuming that game ends peacefully so
which one of the games we do suggest we
should go over first go to the Cordova
first all right oh oh never mind I just
use it okay all right
Cordova against Sergei Arenberg so wow
this looks like quite an interesting in
game yeah we had we see this imbalance
of rook and two pawns versus two pieces
so that's usually is supposed to be
better for the rook I would say yeah
especially with the pieces for the rook
generally at least when the pieces are
best in the middle game when you know
they can work with the other pieces they
can really you know kind of flex the
power of having to eat the extra
material in an endgame rooks are they
have more mobility than then two pieces
do together you know it takes more time
to get these pieces around and so the
rooks generally gain in power the closer
to appear endgame that you get yeah and
and white will well currently has that
beep on past which is blocked by the
knight in b6 which makes sense Knights
are the best blockading pieces but now
white is is trying to create the second
pass pawn and of course we have to
consider what is happening in case just
black just says you know what I'm going
to just capture that pawn
yeah it seems possible I would guess
white might take it back expect yeah we
need to try to see if there is uh so as
I was mentioning the closer to appear
endgame you get the more powerful the
rooks are so probably doesn't want to
play Queen takes d5 because that allows
white to take the Queen and then after
Knight takes Queen rook see a check and
after it takes c8 I think it's well you
can you can also go there directly if
you want to be fancy gosh I'm not sure
if it makes any difference check King
goes to g7 I'm assuming and it may be we
do take this Queen I'm not 100% certain
this might actually gonna be closer to a
draw yeah so I'm trying to think in this
position is Cordova trying to go for a
draw or does he have something we're
missing so let's go back to this
position so if black captures in d5
what's why its intention really to take
back in d5 maybe they were planning some
maybe they had something else up their
sleeve in there maybe a ruckus e7 idea
there might be even an e5 e6 idea I
think we've seen this yeah yes
u5 is a very interesting idea here I was
thinking maybe potential no sacrifice
doesn't work it resists rook e1 is a pen
to regain the pond maybe something like
this yeah I mean I don't think what
should give that pawn back no the way
that the most forcing line works out it
looks to be like black is just holding
so yeah no reason to go for that then
when you can just keep the game game
alive and keep your chances alive yeah
rook d1 in this position and rotate is
not possible your knight is hanging in
b6 you are staying pretty passive with
black you haven't really been able to
activate your pieces as you're saying
previously so for sure this is going to
be a tough moment for second he's going
to to spend some time make sure
he finds it's a critical moment this
position is a critical moment for sure
yesterday everybody taking his time here
it is move 27 there's a few more moves
to make before that time control yeah
and he's a little bit lower in time
compared to a million Cordova yeah
eight minutes to twenty five almost
there a little bit of pressure on the
board and and on the clock of the clock
but this tournament I feel that he has
entered a lot of time trouble and he's a
very strong chess player so that doesn't
necessarily mean anything bad they're
really you know especially when you're
in time trouble I feel that your brain
just works much faster calculating all
these lines and you know you get a
singular focus yeah and and that's it
and you can find a lot of really great
moves and but this position is for sure
very tough to make decisions into so
Amelia Cordova with some pressure then
why don't we actually check out the
other key matchup in the B group I'm
sorry did I say me Leo under pressure so
putting pressure putting surgery yeah
the other key matchup is of course
Federico Perez poncy against Sergei
azeroth and what position do they have
on their board this is the current
position and oh look at the two players
very much focused in this game both
players have the chance to win this
tournament or at least going to a
playoff so a great final round matchup
for sure and white has an extra pawn in
this position their King might look tiny
bit weak but I don't think that's going
to be enough for four black we have some
weaknesses on both sides yeah
so slide to edge maybe more than that
quite some advantage I would say in this
position I mean after Queen f7 we have
these ideas of playing something like
Queenie for a rookie 5 maybe putting
some extra pressure on that isolated
pawn in d5
Rudy one afterwards maybe as well of
course is not going to be easy to
convert this position because the more
we are approaching a rockin game the the
more chances black will have to hold all
the game and yeah but for sure and games
have been something that we've seen a
lot in this tournament and I think it's
exciting because even if it's an end
game they get into these complex and
games there are a lot of lines to
calculate a lot of ideas definitely
tossed into interesting chess in the end
yeah yeah for sure and yeah I'm just
trying to think here trying to find some
way to generate some counter play for
black and it's honestly but it's quite
difficult you can try to go after the C
pawn by I don't know something like rook
c4 I'm trying to double the rooks you
can try and get on the B file but I
don't think that's really leading to
anything right whenever you start to
make a threat on the B file or white
rooks just copy it but um we have ideas
for sure like this and trying to kind of
sweet whichever files we want switch to
d5 and try to really get good at this
white King but for example if white
plays rookie 5 here maybe that's a
slightly more realistic idea to play
Queen b7 no but you're simply already
losing the pun so it's it's quite
difficult to to find some some idea here
for black yeah I mean I was thinking of
something actually if you're not playing
rook to e5 I was thinking maybe I also
have ideas to play Queen f6 and just try
to trade the Queen's I think black
should be looking forward to trade the
Queen's in this position and that's
definitely a sensible way to play but I
think Ricky 5 is actually strong
seems like a really good move it does
allow maybe we can you do no no that
would be too much to punch down you
should not do that
queen of four queen of four also is
going to ponds downs yeah that's that's
the problem and I don't think you want
to go for this line because well it's
suppose to poses two ponds I mean it's
enough and yeah they're little very
little end game broken games where two
ponds will draw so many points on the
board to expect that that would happen
right
I guess horses rook F D eight then you
can go with the Seabrooke as well but I
don't think it makes makes sense I would
say yeah probably look FD 8 should be
played and then how do you continue with
white it's difficult to bring more
pressure well I don't giving up on on d5
I'm thinking some interesting ideas more
more attacking ideas trying to get 7th
rank
that's what but I guess through t7 or
Roxy 7 should be are can you play Roxy
for yeah even even exceed for here yeah
so this is a nice idea for a black I
think I'm finally seeing these a little
bit better maybe the way outs way out
and then maybe play d4 that's what I
want to do so I'm thinking we get rid of
two weaknesses Black gets rid of white
one weakness
why does get rid of another one but it
does also succeed in opening that long
diagonal on the way King yes and then we
can say that black skin will be safer
than whites if that were to happen so
maybe now we're seeing some new ideas
for potential ideas for black here with
we're trying to go rook to c4 and d4 in
this position trying to open up a little
bit
White's King because going on the B file
I know I put those arrows there and it's
look it would be really nice but
unfortunately it doesn't do much Ruby
one just stops the threat that is just
super simple just put the rook their
cheese the Queen away and that's it so
Federico is still dough with a slight
it's difficult to deny the edge of a
full pawn yeah he'll be looking to try
and press this game try and convert this
game but I definitely think Amelia
Cordova has much better chances of
winning his game I believe I believe so
and we can go back to that game for a
second I see a few more moves having
been played after d5 Sergei one for
Bishop f8 just returning the bishop I
mean yeah it feels like if you have to
play Bishop f8 things maybe it's a
little bit tough for sure for black in
this position you know of course white
would love to play D takes c6 but it
hangs a queen for them yeah I think
that's that's why it moves like Kirk c7
you start to become appealing yeah and
that that move was actually played on
the board and we're seeing the two
players right now yeah I actually don't
know how black is going to deal with
this threat if you move the Queen to d6
or something
b6 look new rook
this new Lucas yeah New York to six also
Queen f3 as possible just attacking f7
and asking you how do you defend it
maybe just 97 then henrik c6 and I can
take on e6 do I have an intermediate
move Queenie 95 or maybe not even even
the other rook is well I yeah this one
you should keep that so you made the
right and now if I go Knight to e5 maybe
can go Queen up for yeah it's
devastating actually so what is blacks
plan here with rook with Oryx and seven
on the boards
I guess Queen e8 is possible
it's very it's very passive and might
allow d6 and white is feels good if
white gets d65 blacks Bishop may be dead
it's very tough you're getting on the
defensive with white having the two
rooks it's not really very easy here for
black so not quite sure what was his
plan when he he went for Bishop f8 maybe
he missed the seder with Queen Queen f3
but look at his six really look c6 is
also something very disturbing I mean
okay you can play Queen d8 but it's
still Queen f3 I think is as strong
Queen f3 like it what do you do with
black how do you defend of 7 I mean if
you play 19 7 I'm just going to take you
6 yeah and we've seen those kind of pawn
structures maybe here you play Queen e8
it seems very strange to bring the Queen
back to d8 and then over to e8 but the
point is now you can't play d6
immediately and maybe I'll bring this
bishop up to d6 which is honestly where
it might have belonged in the first
place actually Caleb he Sega just made a
move he went for Queen to d6 I liked her
idea I lose anymore
no Queen a3 Rick c6 this is all this is
devastating right this is I wonder kim
black play a 5 it's too much I know it's
too much but I'm just no Luke c6 ya know
I'm gonna have to say no yeah no it's
too much it's too much weakening it's
not my pawn so I I feel like I could
move it forward but I don't think yeah
black couldn't even consider to play a5
is too much too much weakening of the
7th rank and how else do you do defense
Bishop e7 or Knight d7 those are really
the only other two options to defend f5
yeah but dr. Luke c6 yeah you can
orderly defendant you 6 is going to be
falling but maybe Bishop e7 is is his
idea and then after Ricky 6 Queen 8/3
just trying to to say this King but but
you as you said east 6 false and if he 6
falls that the black King will
regardless of well it's too weak sir
your queen is attacked so you have to
trade first oh I'm sorry I'm so sorry oh
my god how did I miss that
Queen a3 maybe that's sir gaze out maybe
maybe that's his idea okay many a chess
game has been decided by Queen it it
sideways okay I feel like this is going
to go somewhere on one of those you know
gif videos how do you blog how do you
blundering Queen you just play you just
attack it on the side and something I
was going to drop the Queen well
remember actually Cordova in that game
that he was maybe queen of fun oh yeah
yeah three in that game and he actually
came here and in an interview he
mentioned he forgot the Queen was coming
back to protect their drink so you see
it's made it has highest level higher
levels than I am too so I guess it's
acceptable so putting a queen up even
just Queen takes a three and then taking
on the e6 and the black King will huff
well I'm seriously that's that is true
yeah but I think you probably want to
keep the Queen's on the board you can
certainly put some pressure considering
the blacks most pieces are on the Queen
side so yeah after Queen at four I think
you're just ending the game after remove
like like d6 mm-hmm that's what you want
to do also taking there and this is just
a check right it's not I mean you could
try you can try some moves on the board
and look at it so Queen f3 was not
played nicely not played over started
with rook 1 c6 mm-hmm and this is
actually incredibly similar to the
mistakes he made in that other game
that's his true first attacks the Queen
with a rook
rather than just simply start making the
threats yeah we're not sure I actually
like this move he has plenty of time on
his clock once again he's up time once
again he played quickly once again and
it was a key moment and I think Queen f3
was was simply stronger no I could be
wrong I haven't shot
that I think I liked your queen of three
very much it's it's about consolidating
your pieces exiting from a pin it just
it's a movie tempo and you're just
putting more pressure and I think often
times you know even when you play a game
like when you play again when you do
commentary sometimes you're dragged by
some specific moves with temple more
than others for some reason but but I do
like your queen of three much more than
this Roxy six now might still be you
know yes I think it's it's still going
to be a very nice edge for white maybe
white is actually still just winning but
but now Queen d.h was played by Sergei
and now Emilio is now Queen f3 no okay
so I don't understand why why we drove
this Queen to d8 first is no Queen ian
is another option for black to defend it
yes this threat to f7 and I mean it's
not good for it for black that the bones
would be fractured and white will be
winning but it's a lot better than the
alternative voice well what do you do
though if I take I'm not even sure I
need to take d6 as an option to d6
I mean takes takes in Queen f6 is also
also an option for Queen f6 our queen g4
where do we want to place the Queen that
is the question I feel that I do not
want to trade Queen sound would be more
tempted Oh I mean b3
oh sorry what's wrong with Queen f6
nothing's wrong I just I just don't want
to a lot of trades so how are you how do
you cannot do it I don't doesn't allow
any trades
to be done tonight okay this move might
might inject me from I mean you will
trade the Queen yeah
and maybe I mean you you can be winning
here so yeah so I guess you know I'm
just thinking white trades Queens when
blacks King is so weak now the rook is
doing amazing on the you know I
definitely agree it wasn't but we had to
move actually on the board the Queen e8
was not played in that position black
one 497 is 10 and well yeah I guess this
is actually a better try and because you
cannot stand it yeah like no no we don't
have rook what we don't have any way to
attack this Queen again we've already
kind of attacked the Queen we've we've
we've missed our opportunity I think to
really end this game but he seems
confident he went for the capture in e6
okay so it's definitely just destroying
black's pawn structure yeah I mean I'm
being kind of harsher but but white is
still winning I mean that's that's not
in question here
and then maybe he wants to go in Queen
Queen somewhere now Queen I like to
Queen b3 move I just wanted to be a
little bit far away pinned upon as well
make sure that pawn is not pushing but
queen g4 also pains on this side so okay
but there was this this inter
interesting move after she takes c6 that
I was thinking about I wasn't sure and
if I didn't get to look at it and
actually sorry I did play Knight to e5
this position you can take f7 and play
Queen c3 to pin to pin the night and I'm
not sure if you can really play Bishop
f72 Roxy mm-hmm
and your discoveries in f3 will not work
so this is bad this is bad
what is it to be done after you takes f7
that I think like I don't see I don't
see a difference between those I mean h8
at least you have this up g7 but and
then Queen c3 no oh I saw an idea I saw
an idea I'm not sure where you move the
King but the idea would be if you go
here oh no it's not it's nothing yeah
there's just the one checker I do cover
the f3 square and now your knight is
hanging and you can't defend it I mean
you can play queen h5 but I'll simply
attack the knight again or I guess you
have rook takes b5 perhaps yeah that's
what I was thinking I was trying to see
but but you do have some eye for ideas
I'm not sure when I think maybe rookie
six is simpler and everything is coming
with check and and everything is is
coming with tempo it's quite difficult
year for for the black pieces
by different to agree and you really
don't have sufficient time to play rugby
one try to create some counter plays I
think like the only move here if you're
black would be some like Queen h5 move
just just defending but then things like
Brooke e8 rook c8 you're threatening
well maybe not work c8 you want to
defend this pawn but but rook e8 might
make a threat to actually capture on f8
and just promote this pawn that's a nice
idea
Caleb or mmm I just want to be very
fancy today's my face if they don't want
to play up force no no do it I do not I
don't know want to play for that's too
much it's going to allow some perpetual
chess for sure
no I was thinking just some fancy move
like this ah but I don't think you know
you can you can move the hook around and
and and I don't think I I can actually
do that maybe I can even take it I was
thinking about but uh no no I mean oh I
thought you meant to oh okay
can you maybe what do you plan to do
with b3
oh I've got some sideways movers again
ooh
so mmm yeah that's not gonna be enough
all right
why should one yeah me wait I may need
to go in from you yeah I was saying I
was trying to be fancy I really liked it
yeah oh it's too much but let's go back
to our our position because actually we
do have a few moves
so yeah EF was played King g7 was played
and now I this is the current position
yeah familias move
I mean Queen Queen series we're
anticipating yeah
Queen c3 and I do not see a way for
black to defend in the very sessions it
to hold it all together
rook c8 is coming and then yeah I wonder
if we don't check if it makes any
difference for for black so after Queen
c3 just taking the pawn immediately oh
well yeah I think I'll play it the same
way with your key six
and that maybe in this position we can
go for yeah idea that comes to mind
there's immediately you see well no okay
maybe I played Bishop d6 but no that
doesn't work at all maybe I play queen
d1 check but no that doesn't work
yeah but would be one I was thinking
grippy one this cyst doesn't seem enough
and syrupy five being played and we're
anticipating Rocky six in this position
I mean Emilio Cordova is taking his time
doesn't seem to rush into this position
too much just make sure he has the win
if he wins this game he's going to be
first or share first yeah he will
guarantee himself a spot in the playoff
for sure and likely just just clear
first place yeah I do want to mention
now I have just looked at the computer
and I think in the position where Queen
f3 was possible and ZeniMax e6 why it
was just like plus you know plus a
billion knee the game was ending okay
it's it's plus two now okay which is
winning but you know it's not checkmate
so I think really Emilio missed a real
opportunity there to play Queen f3 and
put put this game you know behind them
and just just finish it and go home a
champion now there's definite work to be
done
moves like rooks work c5 are also
actually possible for waiting in fact I
think the stock fit just wants to play
in King G - yeah that's okay you're
gonna check me in every line so I'll
move now to make sure no checks and just
make you make a decision yes
zooks one kind of for black it's very
very tough to find a move if you're
playing teams you too in this position
well I don't expect to wait to play King
g2 but well you never know I mean yes
it's possible
I think these moves rookie six in Newark
c5 are both very very tempting options
for white but it's been a while since we
actually checked back in with the a
group
has there been progress in these games
between Daniel Meredith ski and Jeffrey
Zhang so let's look at Jeffrey's game
Daniel and you're not Jeffrey Gouri
let's take a look at a pardon against
Jeffrey showing so in this position
white there have been some traits maybe
we can go back for a second and see
after that II five move what happened
this was the the position we're looking
at and we're anticipating some maybe f6
ideas for black but it seems like black
did not rush to play f6 just trying to
maybe you know make sure b7 is well
protected against six there should be
two it would be a threat mhm
and then white plays rook do you want
just spinning the bishop now this
interesting move Bishop e6 offering the
trade and you know trying to go closer
and closer to an opposite color bishop
endgame force trades and now a six okay
so that's that's a pretty nice move for
white trying to destroy a little bit
black's pawn structure and if black is
not going to have a majority or mobile
majority on the queenside we will have
one on the kingside so this is how a
parent is I guess trying to play for the
advantage yeah I mean slight advantage
definitely pawn is worth more than the
a6 pawn
I will say that but I don't think it's
nearly enough to to get a decisive
result in this game and finally we see
this f6 move all right
so f6 why just kind of forced to take
enough sex and now black actually is
ready to capture it with the King so
that was a little bit different than
what I was anticipating a little bit
earlier to play f6 and then try to maybe
capture with the bishop and did the two
rooks open on the DNA files Jeffrey's
improving his King though
no reason to be and Lukas e7 so and then
we had two more moves upon and one for
Bishop c6 and black played what it's
funny to me the Geoffrey plays King e6
here when when rook d7 might might just
be repeating
I mean classics by Geoffrey nah I'm not
I'm not sure though I mean you know I'm
why do you think because Ricky three
checks I thought would be slightly
awkward to deal with and I thought
Bishop e4 it made the most sense to deal
with it other than trading rooks which
is obvious that's true it's gonna get
drawn yeah well meaning maybe he's seen
Geoffrey uh as always loves playing
chess he'll do this
he'll do this for hours and be happy to
do so and now he does actually play rook
e7 offering a trade of the rooks mm-hmm
it's really up to white now if he wants
to try and keep the rooks on try and
keep something going or if it's it's
time to call it mm-hmm
and I think Rory will will actually just
agree to a draw here that's also my
prediction it is possible let's go back
to that game between Renacci mabye oh
yeah they just agreed to a draw have a
handshake
so Geoffrey moves to five and a half
points out of nine a half point ahead of
Sam seven who drew his game earlier
today so Sam is officially out of the
running
Sethu and Rinat juma by of or the only
two players able to catch that score so
why don't we check out that that a Jew
mabye of game as as you were mentioning
mm-hmm this is the game where tragedy
struck ends every not have a good
position use up a pun and then he simply
hung a piece and I don't use that term
lightly it was he hung a piece
yeah his piece was on a square where it
was attacked and then he didn't move it
and then it was taken it's it's yeah
final round after such a great
tournament it's tough to see to see her
not go down like
and now we have this position where
black still maintains the extra piece
White has two pawns for it but black has
now pushed upon all the way to the D 2
square and so it's this does not look
very comfortable for white i'm anticip
anticipating a win for black very soon
here the pawn is going for promotion b2
is hanging here in fact I'm not sure how
you actually stop this this pawn force
you know like isn't threatening to
promote immediately but not yet but I
mean you can even imagine and move like
rook f7 yeah looks a little silly but
there's only one piece that can stop
this pot and if we take that piece then
then we're home free but maybe at Bishop
b2 is the main threat here kicking the
rook away and then even Rick f7 after
yeah that's going to be it's going to be
a tough finish for a nut and he still
seems very unhappy yeah this situation
it's tough not to be he's been playing
well for this entire tournament and for
things to just kind of collapse in the
final two rounds must must be very very
difficult but you know I mean nothing to
be ashamed of for not I mean this was a
tournament well played he took down
Geoffrey Zhang in one of the in a
fantastic game of chess hugely complex
position well I think he's simply
outplayed Geoffrey and definitely a lot
to be proud of this treatment yeah I
think so I mean but it's it's of course
very tough when you when you kind of
finish tournament with a loss and
especially one like this where it just
doesn't seem to go I mean it's just a
blunder you know you don't do anything
wrong you had a good position extra pawn
and you know if under other
circumstances or maybe if he didn't have
you know we didn't have the 30 move rule
maybe he could go for a draw - you don't
know you don't know he could offer a
draw and try to you know kind of secure
his his position for a potentially
tiebreak based on the other game being a
draw - I mean I'm just saying from the
point of view of the tournament right
that could have happened but there is
some psychology there actually where
this is this is where the draw the 30
move rule where you're not allowed to
offer a draw until move 30 does actually
affect some players because once they
get into a comfortable position and
they've gone into the game saying okay I
just need a draw I just want the draw
once they get some position where
they're like okay there's no way I lose
this position that's when some mistakes
start happening because they're not
allowed to offer that charges you have
to make this move 30 they have to keep
their focus up they have to to pay
attention and and perhaps that's part of
what went wrong today or not yeah that's
enough being sad though about Rena Juma
buy of why don't we check out set these
positions see if he has any chance at
all to win this game no I think he's
looking at it he's lost the bishop pair
now and it seems as though there's
there's simply no chance and I just
pulled the position yeah opposite
colored bishops so that's kind of
refreshing for him a little bit maybe
because you know good chances to hold
what he would have to win yes that's
that's the bleep here I don't think yeah
unless some miracle you know we're just
blunders something we will probably not
see a win from black in this position
it's kind of impossible right so we're
anticipating looks like neutral this is
looking very good for Jeffrey then
assuming that Daniel are dead ski gets
gets the job done against Renacci my
bias and I'm not even gonna say assuming
I know Alexis Iran is not going to lose
this position right Jeffrey Zhang will
be our group a a winter chess Classic
champion
and actually he's starting to rack up
quite a few titles okay
of course he is the 2018 spring chess
Classic champion the 2019 against spring
chess Classic champion now
with the success here today you'll be
the winter chess Classic champion yes I
wonder maybe next year we'll invite him
to the summer other tournaments try to
join all of them I mean he certainly has
had a very good year he is he's also
been invited for the Vikon say yes or
Tata Steel as they call it right now
tournament in January which is one of
them you know one of those very
prestigious tournaments one of those
those big boy tournaments yeah where
I'll be playing the best of the best
yeah so that's that's going to be
interesting certainly has had a great
year so it'd be nice to see him win this
tournament of course it still remains to
be seen yeah I never miss he would be
the first player to actually win three
classics here in st. Louis so that could
be a very unique title for Geoffrey
Zhang to have mm-hmm
well we wish him the best of luck of
course we also wish the best of luck
you're not doing buy out of it in sethu
but it's not it's not looking like like
things are going their way it's not
letting me check in on the game between
sore oaken and Justin Wang because this
is the other important game today not so
much for the tournament standings
although Jeff Alexei could move his way
up to five and a half out of nine but if
Alexi manages to win here today he will
become a grandmaster achieving his third
norm and he's already made the rating
requirements and so you would skip the
IM title go straight to grandmaster and
we are kind of rooting for him i think
think to do that no I've told anything
against Justin what uh this is a big
moment in Sorkin's career and I went
here with a I'm sure I mean a lot to him
yeah and it's very tough he did when we
had him down here for an interview he
didn't mention that last time he was
playing this tournament
I don't remember if he said it was the
summer or the spring but he did say that
he was one point from getting his norm
and he needed one point one point away
in the last two rounds yeah one more
point and then I think he lost both he
lost both games and now he he was in the
same position he lost his game yesterday
against al Shanna very nice game played
by Al Shan attacking game and now he has
the white pieces a much better position
I would say he has an exchange up for
for a pawn right and yeah it's an
exchange for a pawn plus the the black
pawns are all kind of kind of weak kind
of weak black skiing is also pretty weak
there's this uncomfortable pin on the B
file as well and like the white pieces
are very harmonious I would say yeah
maybe this tone is a little bit of
improvement like I've never done like
this Bishop anyone probably could be
improved a little bit maybe he's going
for h4 so g3 go to h4 good III that way
yeah I mean there are a lot of there are
a lot of options for white to improve
this position certainly has you know a
better better position yeah but you know
you have to fight first you know justin
is not going to you know just let this
happen easy 500 some top positions
already the street yes he has indeed and
he is certainly very focused tries to
get as much of this tournament as
possible and you can see him very
focused on the on the screen yeah
pointing does this the best way to put
up some resistance here both players are
down to 5 minutes but they just have a
few moves to play until they they make
the time control white did go for Bishop
c3 yeah we see on the board we see some
increases Justin's choice no I'm
expecting actually this d5 move I think
it's quite nice yeah totally sure what
black doesn't die there's this pressure
on f6 is quite uncomfortable the knight
on g6 is is pinned down defending this
bishop hmm doesn't really have any good
squares to go to I do like the knight
into six I have to say yeah yeah and the
bishop in b5 does need some improvement
maybe to get some b5 in that would be
good for for black trying to push those
pawns on the Queen side and right um you
know use the pieces from behind you to
support those pawns to push forward so
first of all Black has a problem right
so how do we defend f6 maybe he was
hoping to do something Knight Bishop
back to g5 but then b2 is very natural
Queen B - you want to go okay I was
thinking more like Queen f2 and h4 yeah
that is well what would point out that
this Bishop cannot stay cannot stay
there too long for sure yeah I mean this
is this is certainly an idea to try to
chase it away we have if not Bishop g5
then then what and perhaps Justin has
the answer for us after Queen c7
I think they okay why did go for d5 okay
alright
so yeah it's no Justin started to try
and decide what to do how to defend the
pawn and Queen e7 is possible but but
rook e1 would be a very nasty pin yeah I
think you have to be very careful about
how you hang your pieces like you have
to try to keep them more compact make
sure your king is safe before he can
think of getting too much activity I
mean the 19 d6
so I do want to mention we have a very
very important result in the game
between Federico Perez Ponza and Sergey
Azeroth here we were saying white was a
pawn to the good but it was going to be
very difficult to press and due to some
some weakness and
King and as well as something this is in
the ponts and so with this draw Sergei
Oh huge news as well narrow dead ski has
officially defeated Renaud Juma buyeth
and you see some frustration there this
is great news for Jeffrey though he's
more or less guaranteed I mean without a
playoff event and we have of course
could could you know potentially
mathematically still win but that's one
of theirs so unlikely that I don't think
it's even worth it yeah that's going to
so I do want to mention though with this
draw in the B group as well
Sergei azarov's and chances have greatly
improved
of course now his fate lies in the hands
of Emilio Cordova so if Emilio only
manages a draw in his game then there
will in fact be a playoff but if Emilio
can win then
Emilio will be sole first place
officially mm-hmm yes so Emilio's famous
is in his own hands and Sergei now has
to rely on suri ehrenburg's the
tenacious defense trying to make this
game make this game last that's for sure
and I think we're going to get Daniel
another disc you join us today here I
don't think we've actually had them yet
we have not had him and maybe we should
get Sergey Lazarev as well although we
don't know yet what's happening in that
tournament yeah we could get his
thoughts on the tournament in general I
definitely wanna get Daniel though yeah
to walk us through through his game tell
us about he's come back into chest maybe
we can have both yeah I just have we'll
see but for sure we'll get yeah I think
we should get Danielle here yeah while
we wait for us to round up those players
why don't we actually take a look at
this position that Amelia Cordova
Cordova against Zerg Ehrenburg I mean
things have changed a lot since we last
have seen it we kind of left off the
game after
you know why tooken f7 destabilizing
blacks black skiing a little bit and now
well well you catch us up here I think
Daniel is actually just about ready to
come in alright how about a my shirt and
we'll get him in here
sounds good so what we had here is rook
takes b5 and then okay white went for
rook c5 very interesting approach
you know just blocking the protection of
the night offering a rook trade rook to
e6 what was the other option but immuno
cordova thought it was probably better
to go for this endgame and then we have
queen d1 check King g2 and now Queen f3
and maybe this is something he could
have missed and now the Queen's get
traded off the board but White has who
way too many pawns this position 9 g5
has been played trying to get this pawn
back and kind of get the position back
on track but I don't think that's going
to be possible and we have Daniel
narrowed its key joining us today
what uh what a nice final round to
congratulations thank you for joining us
thank you how are you Daniel it's been a
very long time since I have seen you
over the board of course I've seen you
here but I mean you are your back to the
playing chess and everyone in school
yeah I mean I graduated in June from my
undergrad in Stanford and I made the
decision to to move to Charlotte I mean
that the secret is out by now yeah yeah
summer so about a month from now and
I'll be playing coaching streaming
writing all of that put together I'll be
doing that you know for the foreseeable
future
um you know I figure if I'm 35 and I you
know one wake up one day and I have to
go to my job and I'm like I want to put
chest now it's not really the same so
alright but you're not 35 years not 35
and that's why today so you have kind of
your your backgrounds in education so
you feel that you could go back to I
mean nothing to gauge but I mean you
have your degree and you felt you could
go back to to your field but right now
you're back back into chess I've talked
to you before about sometimes taking
time for playing us championship
and one year it was working out a new
year a year wasn't so now you're gonna
be dedicated for chest we're gonna see
more of you yeah just a possessive
mistress yeah and you have a very
beautiful article he usually write for
for chestnut
oh thank you so yeah we we really enjoy
having you in the chest community tell
us about this moment in today's game
this tournament was was very strange and
my score does not tell the whole story I
was the recipient of incredible luck in
about seven out of the nine games in
round two I beat a Cobian so that you
know kind of set the tone throughout the
tournament I was getting in a lot of bad
positions and I managed to put practical
pressure and practical problems in front
of my opponents and my opponents missed
a lot of wins put together but you know
when you're when you put your heart into
it you often get luckier so I lost the
last round against Sarah sorana in a
very painful game I was completely out
of sorts and so this game I I came out
and I said you know I'm not gonna just
grovel you know it's black for a draw
I'm just gonna play King's Indian and
play my openings play sharp sharp chess
and and he blundered a piece and won
yeah so he after rook c7 with 25 this is
a very sharp position and White has to
move his bishop because I've just
defended the Queen so Bishop e6 Ruby 7
and now Knight f2 is the critical line
that's what he was intending to do and
now it's her rook takes b6 actually I
was gonna play rooks back to c8 I wasn't
gonna play with b7 believe it or not but
same thing win 64 like Queen moves ok
I was gonna think about it maybe Queen
e7 or whatever and I'm sure the computer
thinks white is better but I've got
these lates and chance like h5 95 a lot
of a lot of ideas the black has here I
felt like I had to get back to a
compensation but I was walking around
and I saw he grabbed his Knight and he
kind of looked at me and I looked at him
and you know if this was the like
California scholastic championship am i
forgiven it but I'll take everything I
can get so he had to play Knight of two
he actually found the
way to make it not as simple to win that
endgame after Knight takes d5 is far
from trivial but this night before idea
is very important because it allows me
to a extricate the knight from e3 and be
basically strike while the iron is on
while he's uncoordinated yeah and yeah
so I made a couple of very rookie 5 was
also very important move because if I if
I move the knight immediately to d4 he
takes and he goes rook b3 and if I take
Knight takes a two okay one very messy
stuff he blockades with 93 later on so
it was very important to find that an
immediate move after which the game is
over there was one other nice line after
d2 at the very end had he played rugby 3
trying to pin the knight i Brooke takes
a 4 so King g2 now stopping route k1
check and out of a beautiful move 93
setting everything up ablaze and feel
free to take my rook and yeah I was
gonna take the rook on ok and here the
knight is untouchable and I wouldn't the
game immediately so regardless of what
it takes I win the game and instead he
just gave up the Pawnee mom which of
course loses straight forward so overall
you know I made a lot of mistakes ant
say I'm fully satisfied but all is well
that ends well so I'll definitely take
the +1 score and congratulations to
Jeffery I believe he gets clear first
yeah there's still one game going on
it's a theramin can somehow but yeah I
think Jeffery and is there going to be
you know soul soul winner and I share
with CB on second second third probably
yes we're trying to look at the first to
see if we're going to go into playoff or
not and we're kind of looking at those
results but I believe you're going to be
sharing second and
yes a nice comeback is always nice I
think to finish the tournament with the
win yeah it's a great feeling yeah it's
kind of tough I think for not having
lost yesterday and today probably he
went for the bishop but detached a night
or something it's happened to me
sometimes yeah I mean well I think what
happen is 9f2 is the second move of the
variation and sometimes any mind get
confused yeah so you know the pressure
got Sam it obviously feel for him very
much and I
I felt bad during the game I am NOT just
saying that felt it felts unclean
somehow but such as the nature of of
chess brutal game unforgiving so what
can I say I'll take it
alright well thank you so much for
joining us today and we wish you good
luck in the future in your future
endeavors as as just streamer and coach
and everything so thank you for having
me appreciate it
all right thank you now is Daniel narrow
disky take him down Renata Juma bio from
the lead of the tournament after having
a really good event a huge blunder as
daniel said and I thought it was really
interesting that he said he wishes you
know he felt bad about it and we have
another result Viktor Erdos won his game
against Havana's gabbu Gian we we we
have we actually have him in the studio
right now Congrats
Viktor how how do you feel about this
tournament nice nice win we haven't had
the chance to look at your game we're
trying to focus on potential tiebreakers
and you know for the top top price but
how do you feel about today's game and
the tournament in general this was a
highly complicated again and I of course
at that time trouble very early on but
yeah it was there were a lot of options
and we both play for win so it turned
out to be already thanks polish trying
to finish the tournament strong yes I
wanted to reach
fifty percent for sure and of course the
tournament I really liked and I'm really
happy to know that I got an invitation
for this even since the conditions were
amazing and I realized club it's and
yeah I try to play say yeah I try to
give my best in this tournament to show
my fighting spirit is this your first
time in the US for sure I can see it's
her first time yeah so yeah yeah I was
quite excited that's good glad to have
you here you had some very interesting
games throughout some positions we
thought you were worse and they came
back and and pulled pulled away nor or
some like the one against cetera man we
thought you blundered the Queen Bacchus
maybe that was one of the main main lies
or maybe you miss to be honest yes we
thought but today are coming with with a
win do you think is there a moment
specifically in this game that we can we
can go to then maybe you thought it was
an interesting position maybe say to us
you said you were in time trouble so
maybe around here no you're sure fine
y'all ready seems like you have already
have a pretty good position here I think
yeah but it's really complicated if I
don't react properly then I come and up
force here actually so the Knights are
very key specialty items rubber so I was
a little bit worried and decided to
force just sacrifice sacrifice the
exchange back and yeah the problem was
Bishop after route before CD for Bishop
a6 there is this 95 move which was very
annoying
otherwise maybe night 98 for example was
a mistake if I'm correct because a
bishop be son
first and then that will take on the 87
yeah this is very important otherwise I
don't even know what King takes on King
this time on the rise but but 95 it
looks like a bit weird with the knight
on d5 but I a course there is no
reputation for that so I really wanted
to I mean maybe you can still get some
activity here with birds and then this
is not gonna be yeah so I really wanted
to push it I mean a force in the game
the 92 88 because I started it's better
than square for for the night in general
and of course non-threatening b6o 97 is
not so easy to to be played and so but
here I'm not sure if I said I wanted to
start a g5 but fronting I didn't see the
move after rook c8 because this was my
original plan and I thought it's it's
pretty good but somehow here I wasn't
sure maybe I should I don't know if I
really need to correctly something else
you know because yeah there were some
ideas everywhere so I figure that's why
I played at 4 to 2 meters pretty safe I
mean if you're if you're going to try to
keep the opponent passive just try to
keep him passive and then put some
pretty I mean afterwards you know don't
give them any concert play this rook
doesn't seem to yeah and still my bishop
was not I was not sure about to put my
bishop exactly so I I kept my options
open for but it's hard to put it in b5
cuz of 97 yes yes I really have to hiss
pan is like rook e8 97 d5 and roopd 6 so
that's why I have to play like this okay
a5 was probably I think in accuracy as I
thought I probably should have started
the g5 the same idea and if Knight moves
Derek f6 of course and then the same f5
idea
and his transportation and after a five
he could have taken on G an f5 in there
somehow I thought it's okay for me to
open the king but but since you didn't
do it it turned out that
yeah because actually probably he
blundered Luke f6 because he started to
think a lot after death so he thought it
would be trapped that will be trapped
yeah but this g5 is I was expecting him
to play King g7 maybe I don't know g5 GF
and it's not if Bishop d3 than 95 come
be maybe annoying a little bit I wasn't
sure exactly maybe he's trying to yeah
597 is an idea for example yeah yeah and
route is 6 maybe maybe night before
night night a for a night as far as
possible as well yeah it's alright still
a very complicated basher but I did not
like Halloween I defy so I would have
played Bishop c4 first it's probably
bury him I mean gee 5gf sorry 5 takes
here Bishop c4 to force probably it's
forcing you defy will be fat probably he
should play b5 first III and and may be
done because the bishop come a little
bit misplaced on these three I would
kind of it seems like you're controlling
all of blacks pawns in this position
dangerous yeah I cooked already very
nice to me but I wasn't sure fits yeah
kind of cutting time trouble you let's
have the ability to to make mistakes you
might not have sufficient time to
calculate but for sure a very
interesting
endgame yeah it's weird because I'm a
phone down and it looks like the C pawn
is safely box but ax actually
I can create a lot of threats for sure
yeah a lot of a lot of blacks pieces are
really passive and your King seems like
it's just going to come now yeah we get
this default pawn first and then effin
yeah I can even try to include the King
2 F 2 e 2 D 3 H 4 so there are many
options that sir still makes my life a
bit harder to make decisions but ok I
thought I'm in no danger anymore
scientists are yeah but it seems like he
chose a passive approach and then but he
has to he has to choose among a lot of
very passive he didn't spend sufficient
time here he interviewed him yesterday
you're saying he sometimes tries to go
go a little bit faster think during his
opponent I'm so maybe he didn't but it
looks like you were able to convert it
afterwards very nicely thank you so much
for for joining us today it was nice to
have finally have you here in the studio
we wish you good luck in your future
tournaments and again yeah I hope so
return Monday yeah congrats again for
this very nice very nice win thank you
there was Victor Erdos and I believe
we're going to have Grandmaster Sergey
Lazarev joining us in just a moment with
his alright I'm trying to pull the game
we're still seeing on the on the screen
the game between Amina Cordova and
Sergei Arenberg looks like white has big
chances to win this we'll have to wait
and see if Emilio's going to be able to
convert this position and win the
tournament but we currently have Sergei
as our of with us with a draw today
thanks for joining us how how do you
feel about these tournaments simulation
if it's possible can I speak on the
Russian monkey all right I am
the lover will have to you'll have to
speak slower
alright okay sure I understand each
other how yeah she would yeah yeah she
terminable who suppose it's a mm-hmm so
he thinks he had the worst position
today but in limine cuz of my caught
what yet so boys him they paid for my
mom
yeah that's a peds development there was
the move that we were sinking to that
the white would go for rookie five tried
to put pressure here but he didn't he
didn't go for green 85 in a 525 Korean
rock and King be too
i you should be able to hold this
position I mean you you are leading the
whole tournament and now you have black
pieces you have to to try to win to me
you know to have an issue one is now of
the beauty was this something you
prepared the opening nobody okay there's
no lean you see a bit okay so you didn't
know this weren't from the relief idea
in this position okay so yeah why seem
to have gotten a better position from
from the opening or after before maybe
very complicated so long castle
certainly surprised I mean maybe a
surprise here for white position but
you're it's it's very hard from your
facial to look at your face and tell are
you winning are you are you worse in the
position very good that how do you do
that all right
but um so what happened I mean so he
goes king b2 he thought maybe his King
would be safer before before going for
okay five in this position right yeah
and what about here after Queen f7 if
you goes you're gonna go room d8 and
maybe something like took c4 and d4 is
this something that you're planning to
do maybe yeah okay that was something we
were thinking about in this position for
for you I have some compensation but not
me not so much but you probably I mean
do you want to trade the Queen's of the
board or not it's not so clear - maybe
you should keep them to try to attack
White's King
okay but he played he played d1 and then
we didn't see it very very pretty
friends
maybe he wasn't finding a way to try to
maintain the advantage and he's not okay
in Troy's okay also and then there was
the final moment that you you agreed on
a draw hereafter move ok g4 alright
if Queen Sussex uh-huh
full compensation lots of pressures this
seems like is going to come it looks
wonderful
mmm-hmm you've had a very interesting
tournament here a lot of you're playing
a lot of positions may be equal and then
at some point your opponents were
yesterday was was a nice I mean it was a
pretty balanced throughout the show of
comeon below we're good enough [ __ ] but
it was yeah you were winning at some
point how do you feel about coming here
in San Luis Mendoza thank you very much
how many times have you played tearaway
the move to return you okay second time
okay
and you are fighting to win this yes
that else it's very tough may I ask you
what do you think about this position do
you think Emilio is going to be able to
convert this I think you should be yeah
he was he was winning for a long time he
traded Queens which we didn't think was
was necessary but yeah with three points
it's very hard for Sega to work to
machine solutions when do you think did
you were you following this this game as
you're playing your own game
[Music]
so is this the right approach when
you're playing even if you play for the
first place just focus on your own game
yeah yeah you have to focus on your own
own game and afterwards okay if if it
happens I mean so open it yeah I
understand totally understandable but
yeah it's a it's interesting it's great
to see you fight for for first place
throughout the entire tournament and I
think the result you you have had this
pretty good even if it's not you going
to be first place still still very good
where do you live
do you live in do you come do you live
in the u.s. I feel like I've seen you in
New York for some events some time in
New York some time in Minsk where do you
like it better
am I allowed to ask you this question no
well it's just great to see you see you
play here thanks for joining us for the
interview hopefully I do the kids right
to translate and yeah we wish you good
luck in future future events and thanks
for simplicity thank you
alright so we had grandmaster Sergei SR
with us and now two important games that
we have to look at a little bit longer
this we see them on the screen Sergei
and Arenberg thinking he has any chances
to save this game in any way and then we
have in the a group also of course the
game between Serrano and satura man also
a position that you know could change
the standings in the a group it's very
difficult of course we already mentioned
that we believe Jeffrey Zhong is going
to take home
tournament without having to play any
any match for the first place but you
have Caleb right back with me I have
I've taken Russian for about three years
in college so I understand it very well
I I have stopped practicing it because
it's a very difficult language it has
the grammar you you always have to be
careful how you put the endings for
every single case every single question
that you have it's kind of interesting
but thankfully chess terms I kind of
understand it works out hopefully I did
a good job to try to translate he was
very nice to try to speak a little bit
English as well so of course this is as
pretty close to impossible as it gets
for sedimented to win this he's not
trying
yeah it's trying to hold this position
it's going to be tough to expect
anything else from this position and
then we have that Sergey Aaron Berger
gained that probably will not last much
longer I think we could try to take a
look at sera keen just in blank for us
yeah of course this game is also very
important not so much for the standings
but of course for Alexi Sorkin if he
wins here once again he goes home with a
grand master title mm-hmm and what a
position he finds himself in actually
it looks like yeah why does his white is
doing quite well
there are checkmating threats there's
stuff like rook h5 there's things like
Queen h6 and I think Justin is is simply
going to get get checkmated here Sorokin
still stays very cool you know focused
try to get his final norm just instanc
pretty relaxed considering he's tough
position but of course I mean what can
ya you should not show points when you
know you're losing you say okay well
I'll play the moves that I think are the
best and then we'll see what happens
yeah of course it's kind of accepted
that the games out of your hands then it
becomes a bit easier mm-hmm but yeah I
think both Queen age 6 Andrew H fiber
are winning the game on the spot yeah
it's I mean Queen d3 is is a way to try
to to defend h7 but if you're gonna go
for Oh page 5 maybe
oh yeah I'll go for Queen h6 then yeah
and then after that maybe maybe five
also yes player g8 but then Rick g5 is
possible like you were saying
I don't know I guess 98 is the last
defender of the g7 square but what can
be done here maybe just turkey one is
enough looking one seems super nice
although you don't have a clear threat
yet so you don't have I know you don't
know don't take that six but you might
have Knight takes f6 now the thing is
you don't have a threat which might
after looking one you are not
threatening to take the knight because
then there's going to be some background
you should take the rook and then take
the knight Oh throw this right of Queen
if you play Queen up six then I'll take
the roof and that'll take them thank you
good night and then you think with the
night that my idea has been foiled so
maybe not quite as simple as all that
definitely going to be some winning
lines floor for white here mm-hmm and
Alexei has 25 minutes to find just one
you just need one winning one yeah
that's all you need you'll need to find
all the winning lines he's still
thinking in this position after Justin
Wang's last North Queen to d4 perhaps
maybe the best move that is actually
works ee one and you can still have
these threats along the e-file in fact
you're also threatening your cage five
because now against queen d3 you have
this bishop you showed before just
closing the action of the Queen to throw
h7 and if you want a multi-purpose move
movie threatens this turkey ate business
threatens Queen h6 there's a certain age
five and stuff to stop ball all of the
moves and black yeah and black doesn't
have sufficient time to use their C pawn
so yeah it's going to be is going to be
very very difficult disposition who yeah
but to defend I mean for black yes
so things looking good for Alexei
perhaps he will in fact be going home
with the Grandmaster title well that
remains to be seen but I think it's
going to be pretty clear and then let's
go back to this game between yeah and we
got the close-up on
if he's nervous he's not really showing
it just just yeah I mean he has to try
to stay calm and just play play chess
and maybe is a bit nervous
seems a little fidgety but I mean
there's a little bit of pressure I mean
last round last norm and you have to
final norm you've been here before
you've been in this you know the same
exact a tournament situation before and
it's just you just got to get it done
mm-hmm and then we're looking at let's
go back to the game between Amelia
Cordova and sir yeah Aaron Berger's will
be the decider for the the winner in the
B group if Amelia wins he is soul first
the only manages a draw then he will
have to face Sergey azeroth in a playoff
mm-hmm so now after 97 he went for took
a seven very interesting so now he's
saying go ahead and take my pawn because
I'm gonna go I think you need four okay
four looks natural and then f5 and then
you can't you want to play f6 but you
don't think about both pawns no no no
only give up one one pot yeah you do not
want to go into a somehow of an endgame
but rook versus bishop that's going to
be a draw
Luke versus night depending on where the
knight is also most likely a draw so you
really need to try to take advantage of
those extra pounds you have I did not
believe that black would have gotten I
trust we take this f7 pawn was the
seventh circuit yeah no more drawing
chances than before just still be
winning should be winning I mean he's
like we're more complicated now with
only three puns rather than for sure
through but blacks pieces are pretty
passive and their 5 is coming and then
f6 as you said trying to take advantage
of the activity of the rook on 7th rank
you cannot really play King g6 in this
position because I'll check you and then
play a 5 and then once again you know f6
and
it's it's going to be tough I think we
should be able to see a win my mini
Cordova but of course you know Sergey is
not gonna let it go like that so I still
try and in fact she's a very good
fighting spirit he's still spending
quite a lot of time trying to find the
best way to put up the most resistance
and secure secure a half-point but
looking quite difficult mm-hmm so this
is the only game that can decide things
in the B group maybe we should move to
some other games yes of course which
ones you suggested well we haven't
actually taken a look at the draw that
happened earlier today between vara
Cobian and sam 7 maybe we could take a
look see how they they ended peacefully
looks like they simply agreed to a draw
yes yeah they they had a three for
repetition the Queen 97 Queen b6 or
queen d8 and then back to f6 so probably
this was some preparation they had names
oh transposing into some kind of Ragusa
ng right into me yeah this is the type
of line where were white white doesn't
risk too much at all right yeah I mean
it's the last round
you know var didn't have such a good
tournament yeah he had some great
positions but for some reason he you
know on the time trouble or under you
know the pressure of the tournament
trying to get some rating points don't
know what was going on he did blunder in
a few of his games so I think draw you
know finishing up the event on a on a
good note is it's not bad for him so
yeah and and sam was was one of the
leaders for a long time like always in
yeah he was always at the top of the
pack always I think maybe just outside
the lead if not in the lead I'm chasing
Jeffrey and Rena hajima by oh yeah and
so he was going to be sharing second
place with Daniel Nordisk Abele
yeah and I do want to mention if Seth
ermine held this game softer he would
also be joining them in second place
mm-hmm but though he's lost a second
pawn mm maybe a third to follow after
Bishop c3 no I don't know what has
happened here you mentioned earlier
obstacle of Bishop n games not always a
drug yes it didn't notion that this one
has gone horribly wrong for us a few I
don't know why he did and that makes it
official
Geoffrey Zhang is your 2019 winter chess
Classic champion as all of the games
have finished in the a group he is sole
first with five and a half out of nine
three players take second place with Sam
seven Renata mabye of and Daniel
narrowed its key and Safie unfortunately
just outside that with that final loss
no after after a tough start for him he
it looked like he's coming back to
eternity four and a half in the next
five rounds and 50% is more than you can
ask for I'm starting off on three but
that is true but tough game now for him
maybe the the time change of having to
start the game two hours earlier could
have been and had an impact some players
do not like those changes yeah Jeffrey
Zhang is the champion and I believe he
is here ready to come in for an idiot
for it's great let's hope I can hit have
some good questions for yes so I will be
leaving momentarily well we get Jeffrey
in here sounds good
and meanwhile let us take a look they go
back to that game between Amelia Cordova
and Sergei Ehrenburg so it looks like
black did not go for that pawn in f7
there's something we might have not
considered but he went for Bishop c5 so
he's trying to maybe keep the balance a
little bit in the position not to rush
to take the pawn because he's thinking
well I can take that pawn anyways that
makes a mostly temple and but still what
should be winning here although immuno
does not seem very confident
does he maybe it does
but so he plays rook a six and then
black captures in f7 and now he
immediately plays what did he play rook
f6 check and he is looking forward to
taking g6 okay this should be over very
soon
and we have the champion of the a group
at our winter chess classic joining us
today
Congrats Geoffrey how do you feel after
you know winning the tournament yeah the
outcome it was very fortunate that two
draws were somehow enough in the last
two rounds but in terms of my overall
play quality I'm not entirely satisfied
let's say but it was a decent event yeah
you had a tough loss against Renaud and
looked like he might be you know trying
to take home the event did you see what
happened in that game as you're playing
or did you see afterwards but yeah I
checked the game at one point in terms
of what I had to do with my game not
much because I think my game was more or
less balanced from start to finish so I
couldn't really do much I mean hope for
much other than a draw but yeah I did
see it at one point when Daniel was
already up a piece so that was I was
definitely pleased I see yeah I mean of
course you know you have to to try not
to look at other games you're not really
in control of those games you can only
hope that the result that's good for you
is going to happen but it's very
important I think to focus on your own
game and try to do the best you can and
then if it happens it happens right did
did something like that ever happened to
you it seems like Renaud had you know
thought about moving the bishop but then
he forgot he waited we pulled it up yes
yes of course
so what happened in that game was in
this position
no a little bit earlier so in this
position Daniel just played rukka c7
protecting his after Queenie stre rook
to c7 protecting his Queen and you know
threatening the bishop which was
attacked long ago and then Daniel was
telling us that Rena just touched the
knight to play it in f2 that's how it
happened so he was probably thinking to
play Bishop e6 yes just chasing the look
away and then Knight f2 so if you then
and actually it happened to me but in a
good way because I was the beneficiary
like okay but actually my my coach
before that he was not my coach but we
played the game and he made the exact
same mistake he would have been better
if he meant to play this like Bishop d6
first but then he just forgotten kind of
a tough I think yeah it can't happen
yeah especially the last round of a
tough tournament can happen for sure but
this kind of released maybe some
pressure from you or something as you're
playing I mean you're never done there
well I saw wait what do you mean
I mean you then you knew that okay I
drove this game and then I'm going to
win the time yeah I saw the petition
after 93 takes takes Knight d5 Knight
before I saw it at this moment
yeah at that point I just wanted to
focus on my game make sure not to think
silly of course of course years and
going into your game we were looking
around move I think it was around here
after E 5 I meant to ask you
so in this position did you feel did you
feel like white I mean did you feel that
you could have any kind of maybe ideas
to play f6 yeah yeah this is my original
idea but I thought it's not clear after
a six now mm-hmm
okay and I have many ways to approach
but it didn't seem clear to me that it
was a dead drop for example if I take on
a six here he will take on six with
Bishop yeah and now I will I have to
move the rook to e7 reasons right maybe
they're not rook need one just pinning
you and then oh so now it's obvious he
gets the point easy yeah f e5 f e5 there
should be six yeah takes takes a six and
maybe he could have gone something
similar in the game although it would be
a better case for me okay still not a
huge deal but yes we missed that idea
with a six earlier when when we
discussed this position a six four four
why - to try to get that and then
playing a six yourself probably it's not
something yeah I thought about that one
- a six my issue was was this rook
before I guess I have to defend
I think rookie 7 mm-hmm and now rugby
one but now that I looked at I have this
should be six so I kind of maybe he can
do the same but I think this should be
six so yeah maybe a six was actually the
and it looks like Amina Cordova also won
his game so we have two clear winner
winners here and the winter chess
classic in both events just know
tiebreaks know why if I keep saying
tiebreaks no matches to play
I mean Okinawa is the clear winner
winner same as Geoffrey Zhang kind of a
very interesting turn of events here
yeah I was expecting some playoff yeah
yeah but we were expecting that - but it
looks like we are not going to have well
actually if I messed up somehow there
would be a big playoff frame every
yes yes I think you and Renaud you mabye
of sense of en Daniel not risky and I
think that's about it like you'd be four
players right also I mean set there
Serrano that said - yes all right
right one of them yeah if they were yeah
that's true but okay you had a really
great tournament I think besides maybe
that tough loss against Renaud I think
you don't seem as happy with your play
as I was maybe thinking you would be
yeah that loss definitely was very
painful if it's not for that I would be
quite happy although I would say that my
game against gabbu Xion also I was I
checked afterwards and I played quite
badly so these two games are really poor
on on my part okay but still you're
winning the tournament which is always
great to bring for you as as a player
what's what's next for you know I think
I might play a small event in in
December I think in this month will be
just training but then a smaller than
December and then why Kanzi yeah we've
seen you got invited for that tournament
it's not one of the strongest
tournaments you've ever it is what what
do you do to prepare for such an event
do you have someone you're already
working with different seconds or yeah
I'll definitely have a training session
the week before and hopefully get to get
in Europe week before what comes day
begins to just gently adjust for the
dragon all right well congratulations
what once again for winning this
tournament we're glad to always have you
here with great comments about games and
we should good luck in the future
tournaments especially if I can say
we're going to be you're going to be one
of the players were rooting for here at
the club I think and throughout the US
so good luck and conquer us once again
they
thank you so we had Geoffrey genre with
us
the winner of the tournament and I'm not
sure if we're going to yes we are going
to get
I'm just told Grandmaster Emilio Cordova
for an interview after his impressive
win last round against Grandmaster
Sergei Arenberg as she's getting set up
you can see this was the final position
where Sergei resigned
oh what a tournament Emilio started
maybe a little bit tough but he came
back to shape and he's joining me once
again here congratulations and I don't
think you know it's nice one last round
and there's no playoff about that yeah I
feel great I mean he was unexpected
really I was just playin no more and if
he strode row so I know this is a tough
opponent so I I try my best and yeah
luckily he getting into this line that I
checked just yesterday
mm-hm so it was like good for me because
I didn't spend too much time thinking
about is this was this preparation
there's no preparation no I know I'm not
usually a player who prepares much but
okay it's worth us for years and today
he was like I was lucky that he get into
this preparation so I think the kind of
the mistake he was a rookie for at the
moon 16 so in this position yes I wasn't
so sure I mean I just checked him out to
this position and so that will be a
t-shirt of three and white has a good
position okay so I thought that this was
good enough to to stop analysis so once
he played rooks he for for some reason I
was trying to remember what why it was
not enough
yeah I did it I lost why I mean I just
took on a six because I I think that's
it's the only way to play for a win that
was my thought and maybe I'm wrong but I
think after a four I have postponed
two rooks and I have more than just one
column so I guess that should be right
mm-hmm
so yeah that's by the way going into
this this round we're trying to play for
a wing or did you think okay if I have a
pretty balanced position and the other
game between Paris Ponza and great
monsters are those if that game was
going to go yeah where you going to may
be offered a draw it move 30 if the
position was balanced or so we like 401
yeah yeah you have white pieces yes and
I mean I prefer gesture all disposition
so I have to fight at least because the
course I spent too much already
preparing yeah okay let's try it you
have to try yeah I think that it was no
risk much so because after this Queen
ds3 couldn't be sick you should a3 is
kind of pretty force yeah so capture and
then I for this is this is a nice move
cuz you're taking b5 and yeah and I have
a NC : so I thought that maybe okay this
this is great looks like at least I will
not lose so that's great yeah so when
you're just playing for two results so
yeah and this position I knew that it
was hard but I thought that maybe it's
easier for me to play because okay that
were seasoned Aries to lose the pawn on
d5 and okay draw yeah yeah you make sure
that pawn is not going to be lost
yeah yeah yeah that was my strategy so I
don't know here this position looks like
good for me but it wasn't so sure how
good he was
so I bet you tried to play more concrete
so yeah it was very natural all my move
I I think so yeah I get another C file
trying to get the seventh rank putting
pressure on f7 I think g6 is a weakening
move for black but it's very hard to
find something yeah looks natural but
suddenly I don't know actually after
these seeks
when I play rule 81 Queen d7 I don't
know if these five feet are right moves
because after I D 5 maybe he can capture
on d5 so Queen d4 it will smile yeah
what ah no we were thinking maybe one
maybe what one of the other media savvy
showed a three and now rotate one that's
what I was considering but unfortunately
he
can take only four and I wasn't sure
about this position here yes so now my
Queens under attack and take take on a
street so it can be five and I wasn't so
sure it's been able to capture only only
four more to force black to play f5 I
wasn't so sure about this so I say okay
maybe i blundered but at least i just
can play after visual aid three I can
play rock t1 and it still looks like
very good for me because I'm capturing
again that is if I don't know there are
some Queen a1 ideas of some point we
need for it depends well what blood can
do so try to bring the Queen into the
game maybe something like yeah and I
think it's so hard for block to
coordinate all the pieces yeah that was
my thought but Bishop f8 seemed like you
just let you let you enter and yeah but
I wasn't so sure about it what do you
think about great Queen f3 yeah that was
the move I was considering but then I
saw this 97 so route c6 I guess mm-hmm
so 95 mean f6 but then I saw once again
97 and I say okay maybe an other not
maybe it's not working because I just
have 23 looks like I'm winning I mean
probably this is the best yeah I did
yeah it looks like no natural but is the
Queen f6 is that the only the only place
for the Queen I mean I mean after 33
oh yeah probably crazy - what's more I
would if you can capture Mercy 6 right
you know 6 years to keep the pressure
yeah yeah Queen a for probably is better
yeah yeah I'm I knew that it was
something but then I was like too lazy
ya know we were work I mean worried in a
way that we remember your game against
our guys are over you chased away the
Queen and then
then brought your queen into attack or
yeah yes so we were worried okay maybe
or not maybe are missing that
opportunity to bring the ring into the
game but the this is also pretty
forceful in a year should yeah did you
miss them in f3 or did you see sure it
seems pretty forced for all these lines
yes yeah a trade trade and now that's of
course a nice idea cuz your ruca singing
uh-huh to trade the queens but okay now
you have plenty of bonuses yeah I have
to postpone I know with the age f-pawn
it's kind of tricky and I remember I
hold this in green against much yeah
yeah a long time ago okay so we took
past Punk on it I should be winning I
guess but they wasn't so sure to be
honest maybe it's true I don't know so
how come in this position after you
played I think it was a little bit
forward so he finally is able to play we
should be seven to try to get the one
taste 697 and so in this position if he
is going to take you to go Keaney before
right
yeah and the blue shirt is passive it's
hard maybe he can play Knight EA but
then I just can't move my King to h5
once again I just need to wait and be
patient
yeah with the right moment to even
though that is some croquette idea v and
I goes to e eight so forced to kin f7
and then some ecigs ideas because the
pieces are tight so yeah I thought that
this is still I think it's hard to play
for him and easier to play for me so
just an time pressure so yeah I don't
know maybe I was lucky with the
preparation finally yeah but yeah you
had you had a tough tough loss and
second round without a because of
Tripoli sure maybe a steak and now yeah
works out in your favor sometimes I
guess it's yeah I just try to emulate
that yeah I mean luckily for me it they
went into line and yeah Newport's so yes
finally
great
well and you're the sole winner you
don't need to play yeah I was worried
about the playoffs
yeah I was thinking - no I mean I was
thinking okay maybe I should not play
because I have to make an exam to take
an exam this was later Oh Hank to go to
study but they say okay these I have to
play well if you work but now you're one
yeah
[Music]
no extra work for us also the
commentator sir oh but very interesting
game what are your plans next chess wise
just going back to just try to enjoy
this moment because it was unexpected
the way that it started the tournament
was like so hard to me and say oh c'mon
and now I'm going to lose reading more
writing probably the next tournament
would have liked any form of writing
yeah I was so so so sad with the yeah
then it's like okay what to do I mean
sometimes we just train hard and just
playing and results I mean it doesn't
work so what to do it yeah I just tried
to be positive fun it works and luckily
for me so yeah any for your photo the
end and a nice way to finish the
tournament congratulations again thank
you thanks for joining us and I think we
are going to wrap up today's day we
still we had an as a result in the big
group Elgin
after having had and I thought an
amazing opening he actually lost his
game against Christopher you that's been
the final final moment of the game
certainly a tough tough loss for Elgin
going back to our game between Alexis
rocking and and Justin Wang to see if
Alexei is going to be able to win this
game to clinched he to clean cheese
Grandmaster title or not and Caleb is
just joining me yeah
first final thoughts good to be back and
yet why don't we actually stay with this
Alexis turrican game for just a couple
of minutes I think this is the last game
actually on all of the winter chess
classic group a has completely wrapped
up and this is the final game going on
here and I did want to mention I think
we might be setting some interview
records this tournament my counts
correct I think we've we've gotten all
but one player and I'm not sure who's
missing but circular Borg I think I'm
not fortunately from the B group well
we'll have to get them in next time yes
19 out of 20 isn't all right I did a
good job I get to get forcing everyone
to come downstairs walking us through
their games and it's nice to to have
some grandmasters perspectives there
psychological feelings going into each
round during the game after the
tournament so and it's it was also great
to have both champions of these two
events Grandmaster Jefferies young and
Grandmaster Amira Cordova yeah the
nominal players having good good
tournaments having good tournaments and
yeah I don't actually see what's going
on in this position here of course we
were saying white was was simply winning
earlier on and I think that still is is
in fact the case but how do you do it
specifically how do you put the nail in
the coffin send Justin weighing home
well the black King here maybe each five
I just want to play h5 taking g8 and
back Frank made you or something like
that maybe uh yeah it is actually
Justin's turn I suppose yeah so anything
we can do about this age five it's kind
of interesting why does he play king h2
is that necessary maybe not totally
necessary yeah I don't fully understand
the idea actually but I guess it does
give the rook access to h1 if it ever
needs it it does give the King a couple
more flight squares with the chief
in age three I wonder if after this move
black would have played maybe Bishop
Bishop e4 is this even possible and
maybe have the ability to you know
suddenly come coming to the game
interesting yet putting some pressures
and maybe that's why white thought okay
I need to to take my time put my pieces
together like so Justin white makes this
move Taizo shoes and then goes for a
walk alright what do you think Lee don't
know if you caught that no I did not
okay Quincy dream fun to see so it seems
like hh5 now just doesn't seem to be the
move not quite sure what is the idea of
Quincy three still hoping for a Bishop
e4 even if yeah so h5 Bishop e4 what
what can white do I suppose I'm trying
to calculate something but I'm failing
for the moment there's no roof takes e4
cuz it's not actually background
checkmate after yeah it takes Queen
their can retreat and defend along the
back rank so we need something a little
more clever than just taking off the
pieces and in fact maybe there isn't
something so h5 may not yet be playable
not quite sure why he let he let white
why Sorokin let just in rank just get
his rook to GA just try to get some
protection in a bikini I mean it's it's
never as simple as it should just this
should be this should be but amazing lot
H fun it's five six maybe we should not
rush yeah um perhaps even just some
Queen h6 move might might be good or
queen of floor Queen h6 accrue net for
either either way you just want to step
out of the way of the rook I think we
should do that and then try to go for h5
I mean maybe h5 is not even necessary
when we need to try to make something
like I don't know Ruki three followed by
rook e8 somehow works some yeah some
idea like that is also
like Richie five ideas after h5 once
again just trying to take off the zircon
g8 and give checkmate you do have to be
slightly careful though of course Queen
c3 now attack zero Connie one but you
can always throw it like a rookie three
minutes yeah for sure the nature so okay
a lot of ideas for why we expect this
game to actually go on for it for a
little bit a little bit longer and with
all of the standings more or less
decided I think it might be time to
check out our standings here are our
here are our final standings in the
acres Geoffrey Zhang is your champion
with five and a half out of nine there
is a four-way a tie for second place
that is between Renacci mabye of the
turn tournament leader for almost the
entire entire run of it unfortunately
ending in a couple losses sam-7 had a
very solid tournament ending on +1
daniel nerd it ski by his own admission
had some ups and downs but created good
practical chances good fighting chess
and the results showed he ends on +1 as
well tied for second and then lastly
alexis tirana who i forgot to mention
earlier has actually also joined the
second place players with this win over
Sofia in the final round
yeah for some reason I thought he had a
half a point behind or something but
yeah he he's my plus one
yeah with that win that we did not
really expect it would happen we thought
it might be a drama now yeah Saku is on
four and a half points out of nine once
again he perhaps said the most downs and
then the most ups with losing three and
then winning three out of the first six
in that order ends on 50% victor Erdos
who we got in here brings his score up
to 50% with a win here today Gregorio
pretends on four squares are for squares
it's a modest keynesian ends on three
and a half out of nine and far
unfortunately with with three out of
nine rounds out the a group and here are
the B standings as well
Amelio corridor cordova ends on six and
a half out of nine an astounding score
that is this one plus four out of nine
yeah that's impressive after after
especially with me with the tough just
one loss for a meal
yeah against Jeff Christopher you yeah
so definitely a tough start to the
tournament for a millio but he comes
back ends on +4 and an incredible score
Sergei azeroth ends with six out of nine
in clear second place we actually wow
this is kind of incredible we have clear
1st through 7th yeah well there's still
that game going on which for the moment
ok
Alexei Sorokina so if he went he would
share third place so in circuit Azeroth
and in clear second no matter what with
six points
Federico opponents of the moment in
clear third but we are expecting Alexis
drokken to get it done to win his game
to secure his Grandmaster title and also
secure a shared third place Melik hockey
is in the moment for the moment in
fourth will likely move to fifth after
that Alexis or Canyon
C ground her hurry to naeun is next with
four points al Shawn Moratti body ends
on three and a half
Sergei Arenberg with three Christopher
you with three after this win in in the
final round and once again Justin wing
struggling against the Lexi Sorokin
hoping to somehow save the position but
for the moment looking to end on two and
a half points I want to mention we have
some very exciting upcoming events all
right Tata Steel India actually starts
in a mere four days and then coming up
in December is the London chest classic
of course the finals of the grand chest
or your grand gesture 2019 champion will
be crowned in London of course last year
Hikaru Nakamura took home the title I
wonder who will be this year yeah it'll
be certainly interesting to see we will
be doing live coverage of both of these
events of course in America the times
will be a little bit strange
yeah 11 or 11 and a half hours
difference yeah yeah I believe we're
starting at 2:20 in the morning for GCT
India it's going to be south for steel
for you night owls or for you European
viewers or
Asian viewers I suppose be sure to tune
in for those and once again it starts at
220 Central Time this will be a super
exciting scene I think we're sure yeah I
will be watching that wake up that early
but for watching for those local to the
st. Louis area
we're actually keeping the Chess Club
open 24 hours a day during Tata Steel so
if you're in the area and you want to
play chess all night you've got that
opportunity now during that tournament
so exciting I think be sure to check out
those those events other than that this
this has been quite the tournament
Sabina
any final thoughts about the players
here very interesting turnarounds of
events after the way the tournament
started for sure I would have expected
either drainage ummah by for Geoffrey
Zhang to to probably win the tournament
they were at some moment maybe Sam
Savion was was coming really close but I
we could see throughout that it probably
would be between Geoffrey and every knot
and a head but that victory over
Geoffrey for sure some very tough
offending tough ending for him but still
I think he should be he had a great
great result overall maybe the you know
this I don't know after having played so
long he got tired a little bit so that
could have an issue or who knows maybe
you put too much pressure really wanting
to win this tournament but I think it's
it's quite nice to see the American
player yeah John you know continues to
impress winning his third classic here
this makes number three along with those
two spring classic championships as well
as Amelia Cordova playing very
impressive chess group again yeah there
was not expect that after the way things
turned around after maybe five six
rounds we we've seen Sergey Asura of
just being the leader of the pack and
and always you know when on top and
until this last round we really I think
we expected that there will be we want
to lay up
we thought that play-off was coming and
he'll even just just crushes his
opponent oh yeah again in a securing
first place well deservedly so for sure
yeah and I think in a way it was
psychologically a little bit better for
him because he did have if he did go
into the last round with the white
pieces whereas Sergei other of although
the same number of points he had the
black pieces for having to defend
against another very strong player was
you know threatening to catch him or
overpass him in case he would lose so
that sure you know Amelia did have maybe
a little bit of a better chance
considering Sergey Aaron Berger also
wasn't in his best shape in this
tournament but you still have to prove
it it's not going to be a walk in the
park ever yes so and so Emilio and
Jeffrey are two champions here for the
2019 winter chess classic and deservedly
so as we said very tenacious play both
players hitting some speed bumps in
their tournament and recovering well and
getting the job done yeah of course we
wanted to thank you all so much for
sticking it out with us for watching all
of our live coverage of the 2019 winner
chess classic once again be sure to tune
in for those events coming up in just a
few days November 22nd is the first day
for Tata Steel and with that in mind
yeah thank you so much for joining us
for joining us and also thank you for
the entire crew right yes thanks to
elder's hn Isaac's trance all of them
and then also joining me here for
commentary it was a great doing
commentary with you Caleb but yes this
will happen again it was a pleasure
Sabina and yeah and thank you also for
the Sounders just cup for organizing
this great event giving everyone some
some opportunities to apply some
competitive chips yeah American players
getting stronger every day and also you
know showing the games live for the
entire you know world to see it's also
amazing and having us here as well so
thank you and I hope I'll see you again
soon thank you so much for joining us be
sure to tune in November 22nd for Tata
Steel India by Iran
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you